what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are here to watch the Mandalorian
season 3 episode 3 today yeah this is John
yeah this is Michael follow him MJ testler
guys got two important things to mention right
off the bat first things first Greg John and
Corey are going to be having a real rejects
panel over at WonderCon Sunday March 26th
11 o'clock A.M be there or be square please
be there it'll be nice to have the support
I'm a YouTuber begging you for attention and
give it to us secondly yes we cover the bad
batch for uh just due to the schedule we're
gonna have episodes that were 13 and 14. we're
gonna stack them together next week right
is that is that correct we're so excited is
it gonna be a double dose next week I promise
you guys thirdly leave a like leave a like
right guys this is the way absolutely right
this is the way subscribe and click the notification
all right Michael they should do that you
have to and where's Red can't handle when
you're not doing reaction watch as long as
you're sticking with your own copy of the
Mandalorian available for super sexy reject
we got a whole bunch of crap over there too
that you'll enjoy this exclusive for our sexy
rejects alrighty let's watch this and then
I gotta edit it let's go
causes for the big energy we shot a whole
Shazam review out of the rain and now we're
watching this
the continuity I mean the serial nature
oh look at grogu you okay Dad
I am redeemed God damn right you are yeah
you are Mandalorian again can we leave now
[Music] take my mask off that's such a good
point
you see anything down there I saw the chasm
passing me as I fell I didn't realize it was
so deep so I'm at the big [__] beast did
you see anything alive like what um nothing
let's get out of here she said nothing I wonder
why
[Music] next time oh man oh Dana's gonna be
so pissed when he finds out
I would invite you in for a face but I'm guessing
that helmet isn't coming off again this is
the way this is the way
it looks like a squadron of Thai interceptors
oh oh damn whoa get us back there and it'll
reinforce from the N1 can you evade them our
Shields aren't gonna hold I need you to back
them off by the way there was a mythosaur
down there I forgot to mention that
oh man awesome I've skunked off a lot of Imperial
Warlords you tend to get mad when you hijack
their ships no you tell me
man get ready we're coming in hot I won't
be able to slow down for the drop
surely they must have some defense systems
that's shooting they're a lot tougher than
Tie fighters are you still up for the transfer
I don't see any other choice [Laughter]
that was awesome oh my God go
come on man I have you now
of a Maverick right there yeah right Ave DeLorean
oh [Applause]
sweet got him
so much space action right yeah some Star
Wars in the Star Wars I grew up flying these
Cliffs laughs
she could shoot a Whopper at
how glorious this is damn
can anyone going after ties this is a freaking
Star Wars dream s
[Music] flip the ship
pull the e-brake reverse reverse yes oh my
God Bonk [Laughter] you take any damage just
Shields you not a scratch
nice shooting I love you I know I saw a mythosaur
oh what no what oh Thai bombers wow
to my home again I sit there all day
oh my gosh wow
oh my God you have to get out of there you
you gotta have my kid yeah we've got to get
out of here
[Music]
cheese
that's a lot of ships for an imperial warlord
that is true I'm sending jump coordinates
to where someplace they won't find us everyone
knows about Tatooine tin it's one of the most
traveled places we've never been there
I didn't realize we didn't get the title of
the card yet title smash
take that helmet off is this the song
that looks good a red carpet event this is
the first time mandalorian's been to Coruscant
it's the first time we've seen it after the
fall of the Empire yeah I appreciate you letting
me speak here tonight the amnesty program
saved my life this is Pershing amnesty sadly
my research was twisted into something cruel
and inhumane at the behest of a desperate
individual oh damn though that work is now
behind me and I regret what I did I assure
you that my original intentions were good
sure he seemed like they were he helped out
when I was young I lost my mother
the person who I admired most I'm sorry her
heart gave out so I cloned her had simple
organ cloning been available what my work
explored was the hopes of combining multiple
strands to create replicas that incorporated
the best genetic attributes of both donors
[Music] thank you for coming to my TED Talk
appreciate your contribution huh of course
I'm very lucky and we're lucky okay have you
Dr Pershing how are you finding the city you
deserve the very best doctor after everything
you've been through you're just so afraid
I'm saying Inspirations wow Operation Paperclip
Warner Von Braun exactly yeah okay join us
for a drink
persian's gonna die this season G27 M40 g68
oh [__] I didn't expect to see anyone
from moff Gideon's ship here Gideon I didn't
know you worked for him oh I heard they hooked
him up to a mind flare mind flare huh thanks
to the rehabilitation program I can contribute
to the new Republic just like you [__]
long live the new Republic along with the
new Republic
oh no she's too loyal to Gideon and I've got
a bad feeling about this have you taken in
the sights on Coruscant doctor no I'd be happy
to show you around when you do what do you
miss all 52 Miss from before no I'm glad that
the Empire is oh not like that she's so worried
about being judged maybe those yellow travel
biscuits
if I never see another ration pack in my life
I'll die happy all right I want something
dry I'll just listen to your joke
[Laughter]
it's not
this is crazy how we're here right now yeah
and like really spending time inside of it
oh
travel biscuits how'd you get that yeah that's
weird not suspect at all [Music] it's that
last one made him oh I saw your talk last
night really interesting stuff I had no idea
you're so experienced I wonder why the heavy
down here yeah you know oh oh excuse me I'll
let you get back to it thank you again yeah
this is all just a little too awkward for
me or you could feel something something percolating
so many people it's all a bit overwhelming
[Laughter] you've been a course on before
it's trained here at the Academy really we
thought we were doing good
I do think about that sometimes for sure we're
close to making some incredible breakthroughs
and the right hands our discoveries could
have helped a lot of people why not continue
your research here don't think it's something
the new Republic would be interested in be
careful ethics of cloning are complicated
but if it could help the new Republic isn't
that important enough oh my God it begins
the new Republic is trying their best but
they're struggling sure a lot of capable people
who want to help
you understand what I'm saying she's manipulating
you [Music] what is that it's a rock you want
to touch it are we allowed to allowed live
a little dog it's not the Empire I love the
use of other Star Wars music in the background
here I just love seeing this aspect of the
culture [Music]
buddies refrain from physical contact [Laughter]
[Music]
oh the look on your face was priceless
[Music] I ship them nothing will happen [Music]
should be more biscuits room full of biscuits
are you able to maintain a consistent schedule
yes are you experiencing any undue stress
some Blade Runner [__] if I were to pursue
my own research would that be allowed that
class of research is expressly prohibited
by the chorus and Accords do you have any
further questions
I guess not oh dude thank you for continuing
to be an important part of the amnesty program
have a nice day I'm feeling some anger towards
the new Republic right now once the war criminal
always a word coming he's gonna break bad
he's literally start making clothes are you
Genesis I know it's important and in the hands
of the new Republic it can actually be used
for good I just need to prove it start with
Palpatine stop snooking around you want to
help the new Republic they just can't see
it yet
we can get you a mobile app station men are
stupid
but it would require going outside our designated
perimeter Heist no I've done a lot of things
I'm ashamed of I have a lot to make up for
I don't believe you if your research really
is as important as you say I'll take that
risk sleep on it okay
people were wrong maybe she is a good guy
just stop
she's so strong though with such a strong
person be so mean I believe her I think he's
got a heart of goal I'm kidding it's Imperial
technology yes but it can still be put to
good use can I be honest with you it would
require authorization from the Department
I know it's not easy I assure you this is
truly helping the new Republic finish these
TPS reports this is the most and or like episode
have you experienced any feelings of anger
or resentment towards the new republic government
or its Representatives
apologies if you didn't hear me have you experienced
any feelings of anger or resentment no our
main objective is to help the Republic right
correct and that supersedes everything else
it does it's time for a heist
the mobile lab station let's go get it
good
tomorrow night this music's reassuring as
one of those looks furtively to the side and
back
you're helping the new Republic
it's the right thing to do
you're a good guy
there's something in those businesses
controlling his brainwashed
remember why we're doing this
public
uh just like New York
loving the music so unsettling
songs days am I right [Laughter]
good she only had like five lines last season
I could see where they gave her more where
are we going disposal yards Imperial ships
will have mobile lab stations right they do
but they're Imperial
we slip in grab what you need and we're back
at amnesty housing before you know it have
you done this before
or do you think I got the biscuits from the
scrap yard
wowzy so beautiful it's like an almost nautical
quality to this stuff what if Gideon's there
and she's taking it she's just waiting under
a piece of rubbles all right row
follow me
I feel like buying tickets would have made
this easier for them oh yeah a little bit
go ahead I'm right behind you
oh boy
yeah
so too long
oh what is this Riff Raff doing here tongs
days am I right no read your read your audience
[Music] [Laughter]
she's got Michael Myers ticket attendance
assistant it's okay doc you can make it Yep
this is just me and Red Dead Redemption
thought you liked biscuits
love I don't think this is love this is manipulation
Mike love what's the difference
well that was really lucky
look at those airbag boxes how convenient
it's Imperial Air needs to be decommissioned
[Music] oh no whoa
Destroyer
oh man
what a shot never done anything like this
before
we all we all know there's one thing that's
been made clear stuff that was his first time
on a subway like [Laughter]
spend a lot of time scrapping big ships in
Star Wars yeah I would take you ages to rip
one of these apart you sure we're alone yep
ships are all inoperable no need to guard
them yeah famous last words
they're tiny flashlights
I must have passed you on Gideon's ship a
hundred times
the courage to say hi
[Music] Elia Kane Communications officer
a liar came
oh wow oh boy this is perfect only take what
I need so I'll go into the scrap Heap where
are you gonna set this [__] up what did
you want to be when you grow up I didn't really
have a chance to think about it
just the ship settling keep hacking you what
did you have a woman
run [Music]
oh oh no
keep moving I appreciate the one with no muscles
carrying the heavy box
yeah off stop wowie to sell 52 raise your
hands you were under arrest no maybe she was
working with them [Music] oh what
raise your hands up into two whoa she was
the good guy wait wait
no it's not good what maybe she's working
for the new Republic the new Republic has
some ugly things up their sleeve amnesty officer
g68 has already submitted a report yeah she
bullshitted man whoa nice I think there's
been a mistake and Dr Nation by the Empire
is challenging to overcome this is Eerie this
is very eerie this is a mind flare this is
a 602 mitigator no it's a mind flare yeah
it's a similar device it can be used to help
soothe select traumatic memories let's go
shop therapy you're gonna wipe my mind absolutely
not this isn't the Empire so I'm New Republic
is evil I was just trying to help this will
only take a moment you don't understand she
brought me there it was a trap
you racist how many times I gotta hear that
in the day you set me up
Black Mirror [__] man I love it really
what is subvert expectation you've done the
right thing thanks oh she's trying to work
her way into the new Republic's trust you
are a real credit to this program it's nice
to know that for every failure there's a success
like you
oh no 3D shall we do you mind if I stay
I still care about him of course you do yes
you're welcome to stay she can Flay his mind
into getting what she wants out of him
so honey
that's exactly what's happening
it's so cruel oh oh my
she's gonna eat a cookie biscuits biscuits
my bad my b
itch okay a Mandalorian covert this is how
we have survived in Exile I'm familiar oh
no oh God she hasn't taken off her helmet
since it will go smoother if you keep your
helmet on trust me
of course you can hear the smile on her tone
this is gonna be great [Music]
there's John Favreau she's friends with so
many of Islas
[Music]
the minds were collapsed in The Purge the
planet is cursed these are lies meant to keep
us in Exile yes and who are you night owl
mm-hmm I am bogatan of Clan creese your house
has fallen from the way you are both apostates
guys I bring proof
[Music]
we shall see oh the armor would have some
way of telling all this technology they don't
have a camera
look at all these spin-off shows we're looking
at right here the book of all these guys I
have proof [Music]
he's not a fan of Boca tan nope he fell into
the depths then I pulled him out
oh we pinned out of there [Music]
speaks the truth [Music] this is the way this
is the way
and Bo Katan Crees you too are redeemed oh
did you bathe in the waters technically I
did and have you removed your helmet since
no then you may join our covert and live as
your ancestors once did
welcome Bo Katan of Clan crease this is the
way this is the way
you had it in your man was not happy
I feel bad [Music]
[Music] wow I don't know where this Show's
going and I've been loving it it's Lee I'm
loving it don't know where it's going cool
cool great wow damn this is different this
is very very difficult they're going big here
like how we cut back to I just yarn in them
I'm glad that we did yeah
get a whole episode of someone else it's a
nice like Oreo remember how fun the first
episode was yeah I bet you wish you could
go back there now that's so dark at the last
two episodes this is the way all right that
was awesome that was awesome um wow so different
so different in every way I mean wasn't there
a character recently who said that some line
that was clever about new Republican Empire
not being too different from each other we're
seeing it yeah I I think uh any bureaucracy
is going to have these shortcomings and I
love that not America yeah do what you talk
about we're perfect we are perfect we've been
perfect we're the only Generations we have
never swayed not to keep getting better not
once no I mean it was so cool going back to
Coruscant and seeing as much of as things
have changed they also haven't um and we learn
no lessons uh at all ever in both our real
history and in Star Wars history um but what
a tone I mean that it felt like Andor did
feel like Andor just a little bit CGI or yeah
you could tell that volume yeah I'm gonna
get my one complaint out of the way my one
complaint because everything else I really
actually loved about this episode my one little
complaint is that this was the first time
in all of Mandalorian where I was like I'm
very much aware of the of the CGI this time
and I'm normally not hyper aware this was
something about when you step in a Coruscant
and that clone wars and uh I mean pretty cool
thing yeah it's just it's the one part too
much on it because I was barely I barely ever
notice it with the show Yeah well yeah it's
like it's such a lighting heavy place and
such a spread out and Sleek place too that
I think it's yeah it's really hard to get
everything exactly right and your ability
to build any kind of practical aspect of that
set is just infinitely more difficult than
it is when you're in grungeville yeah yeah
uh yeah but no I mean they had the same issue
too in Obi-Wan you know in the flashback sequence
Obi-Wan that yeah but it's uh I'm just so
stoked that all of my expectations and I feel
you I feel like everyone keeps getting thrown
off course of wherever we think this is going
to go yeah I mean even like clearly I was
like oh she's clearly the bad guy and then
for that minute we're like oh wait a second
she's the good guy and like oh no wait she's
the bad guy um well I never thought for a
second even when he was caught because she
was kept egging him on he kept saying I still
think she's go get this [__] Go Get It
Go Get It yeah oh no look you're bad
she did lure him let's push him into it yeah
I I don't I don't see it that way I saw a
friend who was simply trying to help her friends
see the light oh yeah yeah the burning visceral
light of a mindset uh yeah no I mean it was
I I mean I love when we get these like World
War II Espionage like Thriller things at a
Star Wars uh and I I feel like Star Wars historically
speaking it's always lending from Real History
and its storytelling and this was such a good
example I mean like the idea of like yeah
what happened to the Imperial soldiers and
they're they're brought in and their skills
are used for the new Republic and like the
same way that like NASA hired Nazis to like
build the Space Program um and I think that's
just a fun thing to play around with I mean
yeah it has the fun with like the charade
of nationalism within the new Republic you
know like look how great and and uh prosperous
everything is but we kind of just hunt all
the bad [__] and we actually do some real
evil [__] to make sure you conform but
we're gonna pitch it to you like it's something
of beauty but not in the way the like they
do a lot of I really like that they're actually
handling that and uh I was really I was willing
to not cut back to dinjarin in Boca tan for
this episode it would have been a weird structure
if it was just the beginning and then just
pushing and did you get her name you can release
the cast for this son of a [__] it's just
it's just Pedro Pascal Carl Weathers who did
not appear
yes
um I mean yeah she's briefly in in season
two uh but yeah I mean I thought she did I
thought she gave a great performance I think
it's really cool that you got these two characters
person who's appeared a few times by now but
to get these two characters to really expand
on their screen time and flesh out the amount
of characters but also really allow these
actors to really act like really give them
some Journey to go on in a uh especially for
Persian to get such an inner conflict who's
who has such a if there's something so tragic
about this guy because I do think he's very
sincere in wanting to have done good like
we've seen him help out in in season two we
saw him really help out when he was caught
I was like no don't worry I'm going to show
you how to get scrotum I'm gonna help you
out and it wasn't like that you have me caught
I'm trying to get to get it like he was really
trying to be a positive Aid to them and you
could see that he felt terrible about the
way everything was going that he was sort
of his hand was being forced yeah so I do
I do feel like pitiful for the guy and and
then her you know like I just don't allow
myself to be swayed by such [__] she would
hurt evil that at the
Enderman she was she was doing him a favor
I mean what kind of life is this guy really
got to look forward to am I right yeah if
if biscuits are the best you got you know
uh no I I I completely agree and and I feel
like something that uh the mandalorians did
a great job of is bringing to life some of
these like Imperial caricatures in a way that
really lets you care about them um and like
we saw last season uh uh with uh Bill Burr's
uh character Mayfield yeah which I just I
loved how all that played out and I think
this is such an interesting Dynamic um you
know I feel what what she was saying about
like her upbringing and she didn't really
have a choice and all that I'm sure she's
gonna have a pretty compelling motivation
for being aligned with the Empire uh and and
I'm I'm excited to really quick to interrupt
you believe just to clarify you believe that
she what she's doing is not because I was
like there's two ways I could take this with
what's happening with her one she's secretly
doing some Empire [__] yeah or two um
she's been so brainwashed by a new Republic
by all these like experimental things she's
doing that she's doing this in in certain
but she but she's going about the methods
that she learned from the Empire which is
the full-on punishment I I think she's looking
to create a true Democratic now
no I I definitely think you know that the
imperial Remnant what's left of it uh Operation
Center which you know they talked about a
little bit in season two like there is that
first order you know that that contingency
plan of the Empire and uh I think she's a
loyalist and subscribes to it and definitely
that means embedding herself I mean she did
a double whammy here number one she like took
a a a player off the the chess board that
was really could completely change the the
trajectory of the Galaxy you know by bringing
cloning back and then two sharing the trust
of the new Republic as oh here's this really
talented former Imperial that very clearly
cares about the new Republic um and they seem
pretty naive and accepting of uh of people
yeah um I'm fascinated as to what they're
going to attempt to say about the new Republic
in doing this because it does imply yeah like
her cranking it all the way up in the end
goes really hard in a way I wasn't expecting
out of Star Wars and so I was wondering like
is uh are they telling the truth to him when
they're like yeah this is very similar to
a mind flare but don't worry we've it's like
electroshock therapy we're like it's still
used today to much lesser extent and can actually
help you and so yeah I'm wondering it's like
are they going to com comment on the incompetence
of an organization like the new Republic or
are they going to kind of liken authoritarianism
to authoritarianism you know when it all goes
awry or bureaucracy is a better way to put
that well I I think look no further than the
sequels right like the whole idea of the resistance
sequels the sequels the sequels mine just
go outside and look at it [Laughter]
was that her last name yeah so but but look
to the the sequel yes did I do it no uh it
and and you have the you know Leia gets frustrated
with the new Republic for this exact reason
because this just gets continuously worse
over the course of the years um and ultimately
there's like a very obvious evil threat on
on the edge of the Galaxy being the first
order um and I I feel like that's what the
Mandalorian and a lot of this the content
that's being made uh you know between the
originals and the seek whole tree of the seagull
trilogies uh we're making up for for things
that would have been really nice to have had
fleshed out prior to the the sequels coming
out that's true I mean yeah we did have that
episode I think Carl Weathers directed that
episode when they introduced Operation Center
or at least the interesting title of it yeah
which comes from Battlefront too got it um
yeah where we see it kind of firsthand destroying
cities and uh and it was basically the emperor's
like well if if if you won't uh Mayfield that
was Mayfield though when he yeah that was
a rick Family episode yes but you're absolutely
right um and it was they attacked Imperial
worlds uh including one of the planets that
was supposed to be destroyed and that was
saved was Naboo well I mean we are getting
to because I was thinking about the episode
when they did see the like yeah you're right
we got to get the Snopes and all that [__]
we do we do have to go through it yeah thank
you but but I think it's I think it's interesting
because obviously they're setting that up
but I feel like they're also setting up something
even Grandeur outside of that you know thank
God I can't just be please please don't just
fill in the blank for her no weirdest effort
you know I think the question is where do
the mandalorians fit in and I think that's
what I'm most excited about it uh because
it's it's the one question mark that like
what is the significance of them coming back
Beyond like oh it's great they're back on
Mandalore like they're clearly going to have
some kind of implication on the the greater
Galaxy and the direction it goes um and I
think you know we look towards the unknown
regions yes and all the others are worth content
but I won't get into that [Music] um yeah
why do you think Boca Tan's not mentioning
the mythosar I feel oh well I mean I feel
like they could be like a major asset of some
kind if she could come back riding that thing
you know yeah you could keep your dirty dark
saber I feel like I don't know that could
be an easy way to sort of Ally yourself with
like a primal force that exists on this place
and especially if the pockets of the remaining
you know mandalorians across the Galaxy don't
believe that it's possible or that it's there
I mean this moment obviously puts at least
a bit of credibility to the idea that it is
there that the planet is not cursed and inhabitable
uninhabitable um but I don't know yeah I feel
like that that that's like a uh some weird
Ace up the sleeve or something like that that
she can maybe she can send them in there unprepared
or maybe she can use it to her advantages
I think what's interesting is originally I
thought that we were setting up and I think
it's still the case between the armor and
Boca 10 but I feel like she's smart and she's
out of mandalorians like her people are gone
yeah but she just found a whole new crew she's
gonna try to use them I I think that that's
really the the power Dynamic that's going
to play out instead of it being people that
we haven't met on her side and then you know
but in terms of of the mythosaur part of me
really wonders like genuinely I wonder if
she doesn't even necessarily believe it herself
um if if she's wondering if in that moment
she had some kind of uh I think her question
to den was sincere uh did you see something
like I mean if you saw a sea monster underwater
while you're going scuba diving uh you know
you saw what the Loch Ness monster you'd be
like did anybody else say anything you wouldn't
explicitly say like I saw the Loch Ness monster
and you'd spend the rest of your life questioning
if you ever really happened but this isn't
like the the real world where you encounter
something that is in the Star Wars Rolex I've
seen a lot of crazy [__] yes but big monsters
are all around yeah but this is I I this is
like the ultimate I mean this is like one
day you're like going to the North Pole and
it's like oh my God that's actually Santa
Claus like that's what the equivalent of the
mythosaur is and that's coming from a Jew
so uh it would be especially no surprise yeah
actually we know he's real
[Laughter] uh yeah I could I could see it
being that case um where she I feel like there's
something antagonistic up her sleeve maybe
she's already been there and she's already
tamed it yeah and then maybe she's just like
hey you didn't you didn't see that but my
Secret's still cool right it's not so easy
to tame him yeah but you know she's had time
and everybody thinks it's a curse plan especially
on their territory underwater they're very
very very hard she's on a spiritual journey
to find her faith right now and I don't know
if she there's no one would just suddenly
slap a [__] house I mean I and I don't
I don't think it's it's like that as much
as she's getting back to basics you know at
its core what does it really mean to be a
Mandalorian and you know she original Mandalore
with the dark city violence before but before
Mandalore was ruled by mandalores with the
dark saber it was ruled by those who rode
mythosaurus yeah so you know and I I think
going back to those ancient roots and she's
seen the Folly of she's done everything else
she's tried every other path so maybe this
is the way ah nicely done nicely done thank
you well I mean yeah there's a lot of great
things to pull from here but I I do think
that just overall as an episode they they
had a great sense of intrigue and uh Strong's
they had that great way of like never giving
in too much to saying like there's something
up here even though you could just feel the
whole time like something is gonna go wrong
like you just sort of trust the show that
this can't all go good no way in hell yeah
you know something's gonna go wrong and even
though the trust for I can't remember her
name but whatever her name is whatever the
truster was is a wavering place it did a great
job on I didn't see it coming at all what
was actually going to happen at that moment
so I think they did an excellent job on T
like man this is the first time the mandalorians
done an episode where you are right this is
the first time I've done one where you are
not with Mano you're not with ninjarin for
most of them yeah they it's kind of a risk
for an episode to do yeah where it can feel
like disconnected but you also have faith
that it's actually going to connect unlike
you know like something like what Boba Fett
does or you're just like let's just go to
the other show let's go to Mandu okay this
doesn't feel that way well it's it's as as
we're scoping out a little bit uh I feel like
book of Boba Fett and where that fits into
all of this is the combination of content
that's being made right now is collectively
one series definitely um they're built into
something bigger yeah uh the Mandalore the
movie uh yeah but I thought this did I think
they learned some lessons maybe from Boba
Fett and did nicely to make it so that I think
the book ends of this episode complement the
middle part really well because you're at
two polar ends of the spectrum basically you're
at the sort of you know crest of reaching
toward the you know the The Highest Potential
on Coruscant and rebuilding this new Republic
here with these new ideologies and then on
the opposite end you have this really dedicated
like ancient ideology that is finding its
way closer to its roots kind of going backwards
in a sense and you have two people pushing
in Boca 10 Yeah Yeah well yeah you have both
Italian you have the girls so it's like they're
both kind of embedded in a way into a different
version of Something familiar for them and
now you're watching the kind of moral array
of things that could happen and I feel like
you have the dark version happening on Coruscant
and what could potentially be the light version
but I also agree that there seems to be some
other shoe that's going to drop with focatana
may put her at odds and I feel like they they
proportioned this well to have those themes
complement nicely and also feel Punchy with
these no you bring up such a great Point John
like I think the moral of the story is the
new Republic no lessons have been learned
the mandalorians nothing but lessons happening
yeah yeah uh and we're gonna see the results
of that well I mean it helps that Pershing
and and Boca tan thematically there's there's
something that thematically feels similar
to the experience that they're going through
of a questioning of their belief system you
know and uh what they have to like especially
with Boca tan like and how can I contribute
to the new system of things yeah yeah but
uh like do I the Pershing is part of a new
community with new republic versus Empire
bocatan's not part of this Mandalorian culture
yeah she has always been like yeah which is
such a fascinating uh
we're we're going to a place thematically
in Star Wars that we've never gone before
and that is I'm sorry
the cosmos [Laughter] alrighty guys well what
did you think about this episode I thought
it was awesome um I thought it was really
really awesome I feel like we all thought
it was great so thank you so much for being
here um leave a like if you like biscuits
subscribe click that Bell keep a lookout for
our reaction in next week's episode don't
forget we got WonderCon but before we head
out let's end this with a patreon
I think he is a perfect person to shout out
for this because Mikhail I could totally see
you becoming amandalorian yeah in every way
you know as a matter of fact I'd prefer you
with the helmet on I've only seen like your
profile pic but sometimes when you got a sexy
body you know what I would like is that a
best car armor just you nude with the helmet
oh my God
yeah I think that would be amazing yeah I
mean all that Swedish cheesy you gotta offer
you know what I'm saying buddy Sweden yes
yeah this is the way maybe [Laughter]
um but we love you but also thanks for being
here for so long you've been a long time supporter
and I appreciate your your support with um
being able to hire people like your your Patron
uh contribution goes to pay Michael that's
it and let me let me just say if I could have
a little bit of your blood I'm sure it would
show that your M count is high
there Mike Drive reference Michael drop oh
um